[Music]
Oh what's going on YouTube check this
out alright so this video it's for ya
ugly [ __ ] I bet you like 1.5 billion
yeah honey but who's gonna watch this
[ __ ] I go look in the mirror right after
y'all haven't seen this video this video
is about a young lady who goes ahead of
rants about ugly people and I've got a
young lady I don't want to have to go
ahead and verbally abused your ass but
apparently you think that you're better
than people so uh I have to do this so
LG Austin let's get back up you want to
talk about ugly how old are you to be
giving other people advice about their
lives but you like 14 years old with a
thicker mustache you obviously save
yourself up enough money to buy yourself
a laptop now save a few more and buy
yourself a damn mirror because you have
no idea what you look like do you girl
are you gonna talk about what other
people look like when you on a daily
dose of butt-ass ugly yourself but y'all
crazy ass hair growth dr. miracle
crusade your hair grow your hair so I
look like a victim of a forest fire
what'd ya get ya are ya
I mean [ __ ] we made every pie need
money gum here's nothing
y'all get oh I'm not talking about that
like did you get oh no yes
get up you know how I know you're gettin
wood every time you try to make a point
you got to clap your hands looking back
I'm [ __ ] see ya the Hicks the 18
don't wanna be a G's the foot with the
uneven hemline this [ __ ] know what the
is an Ag
don't be using acronyms that people
don't know AG Haitian gangsta what's up
blue I'm paying on base if you gotta be
pretty then have a good mouth you know
how to smile you do go to school you got
good hair you had a good party and you
had a pretty face that's a [ __ ] me
power you won't talk about the criteria
of being a pretty girl but you have
obviously failed at every single point
that you made and stop stroking your
true father looking ass hair mmm
you ever heard of a damn relaxer young
lady this is what you should do hit me
up on my email and I will hook you up
with some TCB motions some Hawaiian silk
and some holy water to fix that thing on
top of your head you call a rap tune of
a head I have never seen hair follicles
that hatre in my life there's like a lot
will it be true it on the air all day oh
you wouldn't be talking about being
educated when you love the vernacular of
a hood bet on Tourette's looking like
the only house [ __ ] who knows in the
damn soup in the hood accent you've got
that's a speech impediment put your ass
up for [ __ ] adoption or it didn't
have a [ __ ] abortion because your
[ __ ] it's ugly
look it you screaming all up in the
kennel with Joe messed up teeth but you
want a steady diet of rocks girl your
teeth so crooked every time you smile
shoulda let the prison right if you are
gonna do a whole blog about looks and
how other people appear to somebody else
maybe you should have fixed yourself up
to learn re the best ou can do it in the
Brooklyn
just like how real recognize real ugly
recognize ugly in a [ __ ] you heard me
this video has to be back for like the
most ridiculous thing in my life
it's like me trying to give somebody
weight loss advice y'all wanna know the
secrets to weight loss obviously as you
can tell I know how to get there [ __ ]
you got four chins
I can't blame this young lady you know
what blame I'll actually blame her
parents parents of the crazy hair girl
what you need to do is get your child a
check because trust me one day when she
out in the real world she's gonna be
some Xena Warrior Princess looking that
woman that's going on uh-uh but now
seriously I'm lady how do you want to go
in and make a video like this because
I'm not better than you now because I'm
gonna be here just you know clamoring on
your ugly ass
but trust me young lady you're not hit
this because the way you look is because
of the way you carry yourself I'm not
gonna go into this whole philosophy in
conversation about what beauty is and
how is all about inner beauty because
even if you heard it you wouldn't
[ __ ] so here's my bit of advice young
lady you will find out that we tend to
hate certain qualities and others
because we see those same qualities in
ourselves so go home and reflect on what
you did young lady because you and your
hands you take the same advice and relax
[Music]
look at where I came from
mamasay mamasa sky
yeah [ __ ] my bachelor party
I did